well this is Marc Lowrance who you had
two big successes with it before music
and lyrics and two weeks notice that's
right yeah so do you hear his name and
kind of go oh yeah I'll do that or was
this a heavy sell to you well it was
only slightly heavy in this I don't do
that many films but it was such a good
script and I loved mark and and yes I
thought I could I thought I could be
good you give me a lot of money is why
we work
I understand it for the love of acting
no it's my blood I read it if you say
how you sort of helped work the script
and develop the script yeah did you any
of those terrible kind of Hollywood
executives because they're really
cringey kind of Hollywood meetings yeah
did you bring many of those experiences
to the script well I certainly had them
as much as anyone I mean my my very
first encounter in Hollywood when I was
before I ever got any success I was out
there auditioning for some film and I
was in this office one on one with this
very distinguished producer director and
he wanted to just read here me reading
and so I started reading and he wasn't
sort of man in his sixties silver had
and I got about halfway through the
first page and I just saw him out of the
corner of my eye stand up and then he
started to go oh my god oh my god and
then was sicker than any man I've ever
seen
you read about projectile vomit on the
floor and I had to sort of don't know
what to do I just arrived in Hollywood
the first time my life boy from
Hammersmith didn't sort of pick him up
and he was he filled the waste paper
basket and anyway I thought it was my
acting but it turned out Mexican food
the job oh yeah
first time in my life I realized I
totally enough
Oh
the thought